[Music]
I think maybe it's something that people
don't think a lot about is is the focus
aspect of it it is actually like they
just they just kind of make you forget
about everything else that's going on in
your life and really just focusing on
your company yeah short question you get
a short answer all right let's get
started so one of the things that makes
ETL projects really complex is that
there are a lot of stakeholders involved
you have owners of source systems you
have developers you have IT operations
teams that care about in you know
infrastructure pieces being maintained
you have security teams that care about
data being kept safe and you have
analysts that care about the data that
the ETL system produces and so in this
talk I'm going to focus on this last
category of stakeholder which is a group
that we find is often the last to get
priority when ETL systems are built out
so first I'm going to give you a model
for how to think about their needs then
I'm going to talk about ways that the
systems that we as data engineers build
often fall short and I'll discuss ways
that we can evolve those systems and
improve them to better serve the
analysts needs and then second I'm going
to make the case for why it makes sense
to make it an engineering priority to
actually open up our ETL systems to
analysts as well and I'm on purpose I'm
not assuming any specific technology
stacks in this talk and I hope that
there are some ideas that I bring up
that are actually applicable to your
systems bit about me first I have spent
a decade as a developer in various data
verticals first in search then an ad
tech and now is the founder of an
analytics focused ETL company called
that leap
alright let's dive in so I'm sure you're
all familiar with Maslow's hierarchy of
needs Maslow's theory states that the
more basic needs the ones at the bottom
need to be addressed before individuals
will desire more higher-level needs and
there's actually a very similar or
analogous hierarchy for data analysts
basically the higher level needs only
matter once the lower level needs are
taken care of and I think they can be
roughly classified as follows so at the
bottom you have data being correct and
then going up data being available data
being up-to-date fast and clean access
and data completeness at the very top so
give me let me give you a couple of
examples if I'm an analyst if my data is
out of date say a day I'm not I'm not
gonna care about that if there's a good
chance that the data that I do have
access to and hence my analysis are
incorrect right also I'm not gonna care
if my queries take 30 seconds or five
minutes if I can't rely on my warehouse
being up the whole day so if your
organization has analysts that feel like
all these levels are taken care of then
well-done your analysts have achieved
self-actualization and they can spend
all of their time doing what they were
actually hired to do which is data
analysis but most of the ETL systems
that I've seen they fail in at least one
of these categories and unfortunately
it's usually one of the lower ones
and that leads to a lot of sweat tears
and waste the time on the part of the
analysts who have to get their job
anyway and so they work around the
deficiencies of the ETL system to get
their job done and often with suboptimal
results all right so let's dig in
data correctness is the most fundamental
of these these needs and building trust
in your data is key when analysts start
distrusting the data they'll say things
like hey my analysis isn't making sense
today is there something wrong with ETL
pipelines again and once that once that
becomes the norm it's actually really
hard to recover as an organization ETL
systems will never be perfect and
underlying infrastructure pieces are and
will always be finicky I had I once had
a an issue where for some reason the
MapReduce implementation I was using was
not passing all the records from the
mappers to the reducers and so that's
that's an example of data correctness
issue that happens at a very low level
basically at the very bottom of the text
stack but data correctness issues can
occur pretty much at any level and so a
common one that basically the very top
is where data doesn't have the expected
type and so it's basically silently
discarded by the transformation logic we
see this all the time and your analysts
are not going to see that as a data bug
right they're going to see that as
something that's wrong with the ETL
system and that's just something we as
as engineers have to have to make our
systems resilient to so again they're
always gonna be issues systems are not
gonna be perfect they need to evolve
they're gonna be bugs in the future even
if you fix all the bugs you have today
but if you can proactively discover
issues and let your analysts know about
them that actually goes a long way in
maintaining their trust and one
technique that's super basic
but as yield a surprisingly high number
of or detected rather a surprisingly
high number of of issues in practice is
just comparing counts so if you
basically take counts at extraction time
and compare them with counts of the data
once the data's been loaded
for example if you're your source let's
say you're extracting records from some
source and the source API has a concept
of number of records then you can you
can basically get that at the time of
extraction and then run a sequel query
once the date has been loaded to get the
count once the date has been loaded and
compare the two now in order for this to
work the count has to be taken pretty
much exactly the same time as the data
is extracted and from any sources that's
a hard thing to do so in many cases you
actually have to allow for a small
degree of mismatch but if you automate
this and you know run run this check
periodically say once a day and then
alert on mismatches that can go a long
way in starting to create a data
monitoring system everyone with me so
far
all right good one of the most annoying
problems that analysts face is data
being unavailable and this is typically
due to some infrastructure component
going down or a change in the ETL system
that leads to the system getting into a
bad state and the consequence is that
analysts can't do their job for a while
typically until one of us developers has
looked into it deploy to fix and waited
for the system to catch up in general
availability is about making each of the
components of the system as robust as
possible and as you know component
availability is multiplicative so if you
have three components like this very
simple system here if each of these
components is available 99% of the time
then your system as a whole is going to
be available about 97% of the time so
one simple trick here is to separate out
the system that analysts access from the
rest of the pipeline so that its
availability doesn't factor into this
calculation if you're doing elt as
opposed to ETL that could mean
separating out the database where you're
doing transformations from the database
where
analysts are running queries a related
idea is to maximize atomicity so if you
separate your data processing into
logical units of work and apply them
atomically say you're running an ETL job
daily and it's going through different
stages that find it loads into a data
warehouse you can make sure that this
last step here is atomic and this way if
any processing step fails or takes a
while you can assure that analysts
aren't prevented from doing their jobs
and they'll be happier if your warehouse
is a database that supports transactions
then this is really straightforward to
do if your warehouse is based on some
file stores say presto or athina then
you can load to basically a scratch
location in the file system and only
update the meta store once your load is
actually complete and this principle can
be extended to pipelines as well like
the whole the whole pipeline as well so
say you have a change that leads to the
whole pipeline having to be recomputed
there's gonna be a lot of backfill and
analysts will understand that this is
gonna take a while right but at the same
time these analysts have analysis that
actually depend on this data being
available right and so rather than
having them wait for everything complete
to complete treat this this whole
recomputation as a unit of work and
leave the existing data in place until
it's completed and then you can make an
atomic switch at the end and for extra
credit you could even keep Delta's
flowing through the original pipeline
here and that actually brings me to the
next level of the hierarchy which is
data being available
sorry data being up-to-date there we go
once the data is correct and analysts
have pretty high confidence that it's
going to be available the vast majority
of the time this is the next thing that
they're going to care about now
as engineers we are used to monitoring
infrastructure components and that's
important in ETL as well right you need
to make sure that
everything is up most of the time
however just doing that is usually not
enough to keep the analyst happy because
there are other reasons why why data
could be delayed as well so for example
there could be a data issue that leads
to a transformation failing an
unexpected schema change that the system
doesn't know how to deal with or a spike
in load right to spike in source data
volumes that leads to processing delay
Robbie or shock was a site reliability
engineer at Google and he wrote this
blog post that's really good about how
they monitor systems there and the theme
of this blog post is that you should
focus your monitoring of on symptoms of
what users care about running on the
causes and that's sometimes a subtle
point but at the same time it's often
critically important in in keeping you
know nighttime wake-up calls as well as
alert neglect to a minimum so in the
context of data and analysis monitoring
what users are monitoring the symptoms
of what users care about includes
monitoring data delays so if you can
make that information about data delays
available to your analysts you're
basically keeping keeping them informed
and that way you know you've told them
instead of you know analysts finding out
about it through through their own
queries which is a you know it's much
better that you tell them basically also
you can add high-priority alerts on the
on data delays that users really care
about and then proactively work to fix
these issues when they occur to reduce
the total time that the data is not
up-to-date another idea for reducing
delays is to distinguish between retrial
and non retry Belarus so an example of a
retrial error is a network error or a
transaction deadlock and an example of
an on retrial error would be you know a
set of credentials no longer working
right so the reason for making this
distinction is that they should usually
be handled in very different ways so in
the first category a retry bolero should
by definition they retried at infinitum
whereas
a non retry Bellaire should lead to
alerts that need to be handled
immediately to avoid data delays all
right moving on we're now getting out of
the territory of analyst enablement and
into the territory of helping them be as
effective as they can be at their jobs
so here are a few examples of data
cleanliness issues these are I mean in
terms of data engineering it's mostly
obvious how to deal with these so I'm
not gonna go into a lot of detail here
but and in many cases you just have to
be reactive one guiding principle that I
found useful is to learn the details of
the sequel language that analysts use
and focus engineering attention on
transformations that you know prevent
them from being limited in how they can
execute queries so here's a favorite
example of mine this is basically how
you get to the maximum value from a JSON
array that's stored in a text field in
Amazon redshift so the first thing you
do is you create a sequence table it
contains their numbers just numbers from
0 up to the you know whatever you
believe is the maximum length of the
array then you create a common table
expression that joins the sequence table
to the table itself and you use a couple
of JSON functions to extract the
elements as well as the the length of
the array and then you can finally get
the maximum value there at the bottom so
this is clearly really cumbersome and it
would have been much better for analyst
if we had transformed this JSON array
into a table up front
analysts expect their queries or be able
to understand alysus at interactive
speeds so for ad-hoc queries that
usually means you know 20 or 30 seconds
at most for a query to return and the
good news is that data warehousing
ticketing technology has come a long way
in recent years and so you know you get
a lot of this for free but often times
we have to make performance
optimizations anyway so here are a few
ideas this list is is an increasing
order of setup and maintenance
complexity so I recommend considering
considering these ideas in in this order
the first is to take advantage of
optimizations that the data warehouse
itself offers like columnar compression
indexing good data distribution reducing
the width of string fields and so on and
the nice thing about these kinds of
optimizations is that typically you
don't need to talk to anyone when you do
them you can just look at query logs you
can look at you can understand the data
warehousing technology itself and and
just make make the changes or get the
information you need to make the changes
if that doesn't cut it you can find
hotspots and typically identify some
parts of large data sets that are that
are looked at or queried less often than
others analysts tend to look at recent
data more frequently than old data and
so you can exploit that sort of
popularity skew in the data and and
partition so an actually physically
partition the data so most where else is
today's our common or columnar meaning
that vertical partitioning is often less
impactful but this kind of horizontal
partitioning is can still make a big
difference so after discovering your
your partition dimension you can use the
partitioning features of the data
warehouse or you can create a retention
policy that actually retires data old
from the warehouse all right if that's
not good enough
then you'll want to materialize views
and most most teams do this in one form
of another and you know the idea here is
that you pre build partial answers to
questions that that analyst may ask and
this adds complexity because this
creation has to be managed and actually
creating the materialized views and
refreshing them is a time-consuming
process and that means that the data in
them is going to be out of date and and
it also leads to resource contention
with analytical workloads as well so so
these issues lead me to the final idea
that I have for you here which is to
push data processing out of the data
warehouse and this means typically
taking those materialized views or
materializations and actually computing
them upfront and then loading them into
the warehouse with with the data and the
advantages are that you avoid
inconsistencies between the materialized
views and the source data you reduce
resource contention and if you do it
well you can actually avoid data being
out of date as well and the challenge
here is that it typically involves re
implementing some of this
materialization logic and it also
requires additional coordination in
terms of computing and and unprocess in
the final obstacle to analyst
self-actualization is completeness do
they have access to all the data that
they need and the paradox here is that
if you do a really good job at these
lower levels that can actually
exacerbate this problem so what I mean
is if analysts find that they have fast
access to up-to-date data they're gonna
start asking more questions and then
they're gonna need more data from for
more sources
moving on to the second part of the talk
which I promise is much shorter than the
first here's the slide that shows
typical ETL and data warehousing tasks
on a technical complexity spectrum and a
small disclaimer here I'm making a ton
of assumptions and in your case the
relative positioning of these tasks is
probably different from this wave and if
you're building you know ETL pipelines
from scratch you're probably doing most
of these tasks yourself and perhaps
you're enabling perhaps you're enabling
analysts to do to do a talk you know to
run ad hoc queries and building reports
so you know that's basically what's on
the left or the red line here and you're
probably doing most of what's on the
right
so I believe that it's a worthwhile
engineering goal to try and push this
push this red line to the right and let
me explain why so first by doing so
we're forcing ourselves to build systems
that evolve with the data and there are
two nice consequences of this the more
obvious one is that this sort of upfront
investment actually yields dividends in
the form of fewer code changes down the
line and by the way those code changes
are are very are always gonna be urgent
because analysts are waiting when you
have to make them which cause causes
unavailability which we've already
discussed a less obvious consequence is
that it helps decouple analytical from
operational data systems so you know a
very simple example of that is if you're
a developer and you're involved with
both sides both the operational side and
the analytical side then you might be
reluctant to make say a schema change to
an application database on the
operational side because you know that
it's gonna lead you to have to do work
on the unethical side afterwards so in
other words by being by creating systems
that are adapted to changes upstream we
can actually be more effective as as
engineers outside of ETL for analysts
the key here is the time and effort that
it takes to get their job done
in many organizations it looks like this
they have a new question that they're
asking and they realize that you know
just running out of how queries is you
know they basically don't have the data
that they need to answer their question
and so what do they do well they they
come to the engineering team and they
ask for it they you know they believe
that the data exists somewhere they just
don't have access to it and what's the
engineering team as time we do is we we
we figure out how to get the data and we
get the analyst to sample and what
follows is a period of back-and-forth
where the analyst will ask for
clarifications and we do more ad hoc
work to you know to get the analysts
what they need and finally they'll have
an answer to their original question and
now they find that this analysis is
actually pretty useful and so they'll
you know they'll want to have access to
that data on a sort of on demand or
on-demand basis and actually have
up-to-date data and so they come back to
the engineering and they ask us to build
a pipeline for them I'm sure this sounds
familiar to some of you this is a cycle
that can take weeks or months and we've
seen it lead to a lot of unhappiness and
a lot of great analysis not being done
so by pushing this line to the right
we're basically shortening this loop for
the analysts and remove and by basically
removing ourselves from the equation and
this is just one example I'm sure you
can imagine similar cycles with with
other tasks on the spectrum so and
finally when it comes to building trust
in an organization
it's basically much better that analysts
can come to their own conclusions about
data correctness so if for example
you're you're exposing statistics to
them about how much data was
adjusted how much data couldn't be
processed because it was considered bad
and it's the best be much much less
likely to blame the ETL system when the
analyst wonder when the reports aren't
showing the results they expect so today
I've given you hope I've impressed on
you the importance of considering the
needs of data analysts when building ETL
systems I talked about the order in
which analysts care about data issues
and why it makes sense to actually let
the analyst in on some parts of the ETL
system and I hope that some of these
ideas are applicable to the systems that
you are building a very quick plug at
the end at leap is hiring developers
we're looking for people who are
interested in hard problems and building
robust scalable systems that are focused
on analytics and so if that sounds like
you please get in touch thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
question
how do you handle the deployment of your
eto Co and given the data environments
changing and data warehouses schemas
changing or a QA and a new data source
of being at do you mean how do we do it
in particular or how do you do it in
general
what's your practice okay yeah got it
yeah I think I think it's sort of a it's
it's really dependent on your stack
right exactly how you do that yeah so I
don't want to get too stuck specific
here but I think this this concept of
having a that's why having a deployment
process where the the new stuff gets
deployed in in parallel with the old
stuff so there's sort of a warm-up
period where what it does doesn't you
know isn't doesn't affect the the
analytics team right and then only once
you're sure that everything is up to
date and it kind of satisfies all the
levels of the hierarchy right at that
point you kind of flip the switch so I
know that's that's kind of generic but
that's that's the principle that we
typically follow right sorry so so you
mentioned pushing some computation for
the materialized views into the ETL
process as opposed to on you know in the
on the analyst side so do you have any
thoughts about how you like how you go
about keeping the data sort of
consistent and like queries running
across across the time period that
you're I'm sorry but it's like like if
you have to correct some data do you do
have any thoughts about like how you
might keep that consistent in my queries
running across sort of the older version
of the materialized ooh versus a newer
version like how they might reconcile
differences is that when you are you
talking about when you change the
materialized views or yes yeah so you're
performing some
computation in the ETL layer you know
for for downstream but then suppose that
you realize that there's a there's a bug
in that code or something and you have
to recompute yeah yeah sir do you do do
you have any and you thought some like
how you manage that basically and make
sure that queries don't get both old
versions and new versions or you know
I'm sorry I'm not sure if I understand
exactly we mean do you mean you mean if
you're fixing a bug to the
materialization code itself or yes yeah
so you might have an older version of
the materialized view that might have a
mistake in it and then at the same time
you're creating a new version of that
data yeah right but then your queries
might be running against both old and
new versions at the same time like is
there no I see yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's is it my answer is gonna be very
similar to my previous answer we try to
or what we found is it's best to kind of
keep keep the new and old completely
separate from each other and do the do
the complete recomputation first right
before you really touch the old stuff at
all and then and then make an atomic
switch so that you know you never have
queries that are like a query would only
be touching one or the other
yeah I'm not sure if that really
answered your question yeah that's good
hi I have a two-part question so the
second part is related to the first one
so in the first question I have this
query that do you think that data
analysts and data engineers should be
involved from the beginning in the
project planning because in my
experience I felt that there's a general
disconnect between the data warehouse
and the requirements are the unlist
feel that they need to have so we end up
doing a lot of rework or if we might
even have to go back in the reiterated
cycle second if you think that the first
part can coexist like we can have a
mutually agreeable data model then can
an ETL warehouse system be developed
which will be self self-sustaining
implying that you don't need to refresh
the data it can be handled automatically
or maybe minimal effort can be required
and likewise the data requirement that
the analyst would have would be
comparatively easier for them to get and
much much easier for the data engineer
to manage thank you yes good questions
sorry let me go back to this slide so so
yes absolutely
include your analysts as early as
possible in the process right it's kind
of like it's kind of like building a new
system or building a new product right
you want to understand the requirements
first right like before you do anything
so so yeah by involving analysts early
it did it it just helps in many ways
later and in the second part yeah like
you know there's there's an initial
investment right when you build systems
that that that can evolve right like
it's it's it's hard it's not easy to
push this line to the right but but
basically by doing so it makes life
easier for everybody right it makes life
easier for analysts who get a sort of
shorter cycle time and getting their
work done and it makes our job easier as
well because there's sort of less
there's less stuff we have to manage and
be involved in and so what we find is is
when when engineers are able to do this
they can they can kind of leave sort of
leave this behind and focus on more
or interesting projects yeah typically
most of these tasks are not super
interesting from an engineering
perspective
yeah this morning could you give us an
example of you know how do you move that
line to the right I mean what are some
things in your organization that you've
done or things that you've seen done
that actually enables that line to move
to the right and you know pushing tasks
kind of off the engineering palate and
into the hands of the analyst so there
are many ways of going about it
and I think sound like a broken record
here but it's kind of stacked dependent
so you know you can you can actually
some of this you can you can solve with
with a good bi tool right like so you're
using looker and you can actually you
know have the analysts create the data
model and and materializations through
the tool itself yeah let's see what are
what are other things you can do you can
um another thing that that works well is
to have a pretty strict schema for data
that your team's produce locally right
so you can you know if you're using
Kafka for example to publish publish
data internally then you can have you
can develop methods for for actually
evolving the schemas ready you never
want to lock yourself to a schema but
you can you know if you're using
confluence schema registry for example
you can actually create you know as
developers you can create a method for
how how your team's evolved schemas over
time right so so that goes a long way in
in you know not not having to worry too
much about scheme evolution in your in
your transformation logic yeah those are
a couple of a couple of examples so so
my question is how say there's an
engineer imbalance between say patch
data versus trimming data so does your
have any suggestion say if you do the
patch data a simpler approach because
you don't handle all the tip different
say it's up there
um because basically you can go back
reload something or because some data
are time sensitive say status changes
right it's even though the source data
may actually be incremental but some of
those dimensions or facts could change
afterwards how do you handle situation
next say for example there's flack right
right now is said okay but after 2 days
right you get that response so we have a
customer who actually mayor the kind of
engagement of the customer right so that
engagement means say two days later is
in the email and that's like changes so
high say how you handle say for example
the in the past level handling over
versus streaming Evo handling also how
the handle can expect it data changes so
the first thing I would do is figure out
what your analysts want right like what
how do how do they want to see these
these changes reflected in the data that
they are querying right so they might
want snapshots right they might want
historical views and I don't I don't
actually think that whether you're doing
batch processing or streaming processing
you know what kind of architecture you
have you know it's it's not like you can
only do one or the other right with you
know depending on on which wish which
sort of data processing architecture you
have so yes I don't I don't think I
don't think that necessarily has a
direct impact yeah I think that's all
about that
so I'm wondering in that distinction is
or do you think it's possible that you
can shift that now I don't know if you
specified but if like if you can
actually move that line maybe a little
further to the right or left but it
would depend on what kind of people you
have for example you think shifted
depending on like where it ends up kind
of if I for example person you know yeah
like I I don't know how many analysts
would have the skillset to handle all
that so I don't know like if you had to
experience like yeah save data engineers
training analysts they can pick up those
skills right or you just say like on the
Job Description
that's what it yeah you know you should
be able to handle all those skills as
well yeah it seems like it's pretty rare
yeah yeah so clarification here what I
mean by pushing this line to the right
is is is not training right like I don't
I don't what I mean is we can build
systems that actually let the analysts
do this stuff in ways that make sense to
them right so it requires abstractions
and it requires tool tool support and I
see a lot of I you know I see a lot of
job descriptions that ask for you know
skills on both sides right you know you
have to be you know you have to be a
super detail-oriented analyst but you
know by the way you also need to know
how to operate spark right like those
people I mean there are some of them but
they're really hard to find and I know I
said we advise the companies that we
work with to try and try and focus our
efforts on finding people who are really
good at one or the other and not both so
so yeah what I really mean here is you
know build systems that that give the
analyst tools to do things in the way
that makes sense to them
[Music]